dirty little fish swimming around great
to be dirty
that is Richard Dreyfuss playing Bernie
Madoff in the new ABC miniseries which
airs next month of course Madoff is the
investment manager serving 150 years in
prison for ripping off his client's wife
Danner plays his wife Ruth and we were
first on the set I can't take you money
because it's just not enough for me to
bother with Richard is kidding around
but the subject is deadly serious madoff
defrauded thousands of investors out of
nearly 65 billion dollars in the largest
Ponzi scheme in history when s mom
Blythe is his wife who was blind to the
scandal I'm the vice-president and then
all I do is hire the decorators it's
really complicated I think they did love
each other very very deeply I think I
don't know that you'd ever really she
never absorbed what happened I don't
believe she knew they call me a fraud
you know I ran the biggest Ponzi scheme
in history okay
within the biggest Ponzi scheme in
history the ABC miniseries is personal
for Richard he has friends who lost
their savings to Madoff you know how I
look at you now as a guy who doubled my
money in six years we've talked to
victims and none of them are many there
were all secretaries and
and everyone assumed wow must be really
great and they weren't and they're not
people give me their money and I make
them richer than God how much did you
lose fifty billion dollars I'm exhausted
after one scene and he just goes on and
on and on and always brilliant it's the
kind of actor you want to always work
with oh stop honest I'm not lying
you know you Blythe and Richard have a
long history they first worked together
in theatre back in 1971 after all these
years we were kids when we get begin you
know we asked Blythe if a certain famous
family member her daughter went a
paltrow ever paid a visit to her on the
set while she was working and by said no
because when she is working she likes to
stay focused in other words kids don't
bother mama when she is focused I guess
kids can be distracting no matter what
the age right